un bond à jo est ce que tu peux nous
faire juste là un petit live parce qu'il
ya des risques et la est ce que tu peux
nous faire en avant-première pour tp un
extrait de moi cia congo on prononce ce
mois-ci bien entendu un est ce que tu
peux nous faire ça une petite minute ça
parce que c'est vraiment à life c'est un
petit kiff qu'on nous fait est que nous
fait mon badge ou tu peux monde à djouba
ouais je veux juste préciser sur profit
de l'association ce titre exactement ce
sont les jeux le sort justement pour
pour la version demain à minuit et et
tous les stream tu vois les simples
curieux que tout ce que va va collecter
ce titre que va générer comme argent
cette matinée toutes et tous pour
l'association regards bravo mon job asie
mais ça y est coupée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
notre amour et la vie les soins gérés
les deux côtés sophie isabelle du bape
au sol
les logos des cherry quoi qu'il arrive
je resterai de ton côté émises a raconté
l'une à coaticook bogota je suis venu à
toi pour t'empêcher de souffrir à
l'ombre des mots tu es ma nana pwnage et
art parle moi je prendrais le temps de
débouter
la boillat solomon lobera et aux
amateurs et mois ci un combat mayebi
n'est pas facile laisse-moi de soulager
moi si un combat laillé birmanie par ci
laisse moi te soulager
[Musique]
gâtés au démarrage en at on dit si
malouda échos datés ou mois ci a commis
pas si les mois de cela
[Musique]
groban a sauté du modem à nailloux et
puis là le goty papa sinagot et si li na
s'était dit
serena
et moi zinal
sinon moi s'y attend
was in amenas
moi
nevio money pas six mois tous soulagés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]